hello everyone some of you might
remember me mentioning in the previous
video that I will be leaving for
Dubrovnik somewhere around tomorrow and
I will not be able to to create any
content for some six days up until next
Wednesday so I have decided to
pre-record
six games by a rashida Schmidt deunov
and I will upload them and I will
publish them every day at 8 8 p.m.
Central European Time or I believe it's
Central European summer time so that
being said this is the first game in the
series so six very nice games by Rashid
in German do you know it's a wild game
where a lot of things could have gone
wrong it's played in 1947 and he's
playing against Alexis waiting some of
you may remember that video I did
against towel versus wetting the the
game called not bad for a dead man it's
it's a very nice game by towel if you
haven't seen it I will put a link to it
in the description below so you're very
welcome to check it out so let's see
this game rush it has the white pieces
and he opens with E 4 we have C 5 the
Sicilian defense sweatin is not afraid
to go for a nice sharp line against the
error sheet Knight to f3 Knight to c6
and the d4 we have captures Knight
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
the d6 now the classical variation
Bishop to g5 we have e 6 and the Bishop
to c4 and as Madinah of develops a piece
with every move he makes we have a 6 and
here you could continue in a lot of ways
but Rashid goes for the for the
immediate Knight captures on c6 we have
pawn captures and now II five a very
nice pawn sacrifice here
bye-bye image Medina of and although D
captures on e5 is something you could
actually play and you could allow Queen
captures here King captures but it's
something a computer will do it's it's
very hard for a human to commit to
something like this after after your
Castle Knight d5 is coming and black is
actually perfectly fine here regardless
of of the doubled pawn I mean he is up
opponent but it's his pawn structure is
all messed up and while this is playable
for black a human
will not play something like this so we
have Queen to a5 by sweatin now of
course capturing is impossible because
of Queen captures Bishop so instead
after this Queen to a5 we have Bishop
captures on f6 pawn captures on f6 and
now pawn captures on d6 it seems now
that White has a very nice past D pawn
but in fact Queen e5 takes care of that
immediately
this comes with check and there are a
couple of ways you can deal with this
but unless Medina already decided that
this game he is going all out and he
instead of blocking with the Queen or
something he plays King to f1 so for the
time being it will be somewhat difficult
to get the h1 rook into the game Queen
captures on d6 offering a trade of
Queens and now Queen to f3 so here ok
you did sacrifice some material blacks
King is still in the center but White's
King is on f1 so unless white manages to
fix this this rook is not really coming
into the game at the moment Queen
captures on f6 is the threat and the way
you want to take care of this is either
Bishop to e7 or Bishop to g7 and here is
a the first small inaccuracy so 18 makes
we have f5 Bishop to e7 or g7 would have
been better you develop a piece you can
you allow the rook to come into the game
and most of all you're not creating any
targets and by pushing this pawn to f5
this will now become a target
first Rasheed brings the rook into the
game we are rook to d1 this comes with a
tempo as it's attacking the Queen Queen
moves to c7 and now comes g4 now you can
see that the DF 5 pawn has become a
target and Rashid immediately goes for
it he doesn't allow black any chances to
consolidate not capturing on g4 for
example f4 that doesn't really work
because now you allow 90 for you you've
created this nicéphore square for the
knight and after Bishop to e7 then comes
g5 and it's it's very unpleasant here
for black
so after g4 f captures on g4 by sweatin
we have Queen captures on g4 and now
Bishop the b7 Bishop the b7 a second
I'm much bigger in accuracy here with h5
you can still play the game either force
whites to f3 maybe g3 although it's
highly unlikely
Rasheed would have gone for the Queen
trade but you know you you're not
committing to anything and you still
want to see what what is White's plan
but here after Bishop to b7 you've just
moved this Bishop to b7 okay you are
preparing to bring the rook into the
game but this Bishop is now a terrible
piece so for now it's until they push c5
it's actually like a pawn and under
another thing you are no longer keeping
an eye and the e6 pawn and you are
playing against arashikage Medina so
without further ado Bishop captures on
e6 a Rashid sacrifices the Bishop F
captures and now for some reason a
moment of blindness for Rashid here rook
to g1 would have been the strongest idea
he immediately went for Queen captures
and e6 the idea behind Brooke to g1 is
that you can't really defend this
exponent but you have now brought to the
rook into the game you have to you have
to allow whites to capture here if you
try to defend it for example Queen to f7
you get Queen d4 and now there's really
not all that much you can do attacking
the rook on h8 after the rook moves now
comes rook captures Queen captures Queen
d7 this would be checkmate but in a lot
of other variations of white will also
prevail here we have Queen captures on
e6 and now Bishop to e7 was played here
sweatin actually had a very nice
opportunity to have to really get out of
everything as he could have also blocked
with Queen to e7 but to actually play
Queen to e7 you have to see very far
into the future this is what both news
Medina and Satan missed and probably a
finish Medina of saw Queen e7 and the
White Queen e7 works he would have gone
for that Ruby g1 line but okay Queenie 7
and this is the idea why it works you
have to move the Queen let's say Queen
f5 and now the bishop comes back into
the game
okay butter up c8 Queen to h5 check now
you can see that the rook is controlling
the entire the entire D file and after
Queen to f7 blocking now comes Queen to
e5 checking the King
attacking the rook this is probably what
nature Medina saw that this couldn't
possibly work for black and sweaty and
also saw this and said okay I can't play
this but both of them actually missed
this move Queen e7 that's right
and now white has to repeat Queen h5
check Queenie five check and settle with
a draw
I forgot the rook then you lose the game
Bishop h3 check I noticed that the Queen
is now covering d1 square King do you
wanna only move Queen g5 this will be
checkmate so a very nice idea but you
know you can't hold it against sweating
for not going 27 because who'd found
that find that in in a real game or
maybe nurture Medina saw it and he was
simply bluffing it's hard to say but
okay Bishop to e7
now comes Knight e4 allowing this Knight
now into the game and the queen is not
under attack by the by the black queen
so basically a free move to get the
knight into the attack the ship to see
it of course now you have to activate
the bishop which was so poorly you know
the station that b7 Knight to f6 check
we have King to f8 only move and now
comes rope to d7 this is a very nice
moment in the game because once again
energy Medina misses the opportunity to
win the game with Knight d7 immediately
because now of course you don't wanna
and don't want to go to g7 allowing
groups you want with check but the idea
after here is that after rubgy one ruiji
eight wins the game and this is the
second time in the game era she'd either
missed or decided not to go for this
room g1 idea because now whatever you
play room g8 will win the game even
capturing here still you get Ruby g8
check captures captures you have to
block and now comes rook e1 check and
now it's all over you will you're either
getting checkmated or you're gonna lose
a whole lot of material first you have
to make some room for the King Queen
captures Bishop blocks now Queen checks
King moves the rook is captured and now
you are a queen and the rook against the
Queen and the bishop Plus why this upper
pond completely winning position so I've
took him to a fate a trashy to go again
doesn't go for Ruby g1 for some reason
he he he decided not to play with this
rook in this game he goes for the fancy
light
rook to d7 of course the thread is Queen
captures on e7 with checkmate so you do
have to prevent this here we have Bishop
captures on b7 and again sweating both
sweating and energy you know missed a
very nice defensive resource here so
okay maybe it's a nice opportunity for
you to pause the video and try to find
the the defensive idea sweatin missed so
you are black here energy Medina is
really coming for you hard and you have
to defend this position what you play
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
defender as it seems both of them have
missed it
well sweating missed it definitely it's
hard to save energy Medina saw it but
the move that successfully defends black
here is actually Queen to d6 Queen to d6
now of course if captures then Bishop
captures Queen and as black is up
material it's not all that big of a deal
if for example rook captures Queen
Bishop captures rook captures now comes
King f7 and you attack the rook end the
night the night is now attacked twice so
if you move the rook you're gonna lose
the night so here you have to capture
row capture screen captures and after
Knight moves it's actually black with
two rooks against a rock and the night
although being down to pawns
black black should be better here so
definitely a nice idea as waiting missed
so after rule d7 Bishop captures on d7
was played but now comes Knight captures
on b7 would check King e8 and now Knight
back to have sex with check King to d8
if you go King to f8 if King to f8 then
again rubgy one is deadly with the
threat of Ruby 8 check followed by a
queen captors and g8 checkmate so here
after Bishop captures it's quite simple
Queen captures King moves Queen captures
and h8 King moves Queen captures with
check here you get a check and after
captures captures captures
it's a I mean white is the white is up a
whole rook
so after Knight to f6 sweat and tried
King to d8 but now comes skinny to
finally making room for this rook to
enter the game not to be a g1 as you
know everyone would have expected for
the entire game but rather be a d1 d1
and here Queen to d6 was played you
have to part with the Queen if you try
defending something like Queen c8
offering a trade of Queens preparing to
move the King it doesn't work rugby 1
check King moves now you lose the bush
or King moves and now after check it's
all over king b7 check move checkmate a
very nice a very nice line and after
King to e2 Queen to d6 was an attempt by
sweating I would have rugby 1 now
connecting with the Queen and the king
Queen captures King captures and now
Bishop captures on f6 Queen captures and
team to c7 now black managed to save
both rooks and it's two rooks against
the Queen we have Queen e7 check King
moves and now c4 and it was in this
position that Alex is sweating resigned
the game why did he resign usually two
rooks will compensate for the Queen but
not here the king is very lonely and b6
and there aren't all that many squares
he can use from this but this position
you can only use the a5 square and here
well let's say something like rook a to
d8
check is played King moves rock the
other broker has to come into the game
see if I for example pushing the King
deeper into the position King comes now
comes Queen to a7 threatening Queen b6
rogue blocks
now for example King c3 not allowing
King to escape via King to c4 and after
something like rope to a fate going for
rook f3 check to harass the white king
then comes a for you cannot capture late
for pawn because Queen captures on a6
and after King moves now comes Queen c7
check King captures Queen captures King
a5 and now after G after b3 there is no
defense against the Queen to a for
checkmate also the Queen from c6 is
covering f3 so no no checks are pretty
useful here so yeah a very nice game by
Rasheed nourishment universal access to
18 after c4 so I didn't resign the game
and this this wonderful wonderful game
daffle of missed opportunities for both
players you know so I didn't missed a
very nice defensive resource twice and
energy Medina of twice failed to act in
the Ruby g1 way so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Gil traits and I got mattress dog
for a conversion too
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it now like I said I will be
going to Dubrovnik and I will stay there
until next Wednesday so I have prepared
six Rashid engagement you know videos
each of them will be up will be
published every day at 8 p.m. Central
European summer time so I do hope you
will enjoy this kind of rush engagement
you know series and after I returned
from Dubrovnik we're gonna we're gonna
attack the the Bobby Fischer series as
you as most of you have voted for that
series so and yeah I'm gonna be a way
for like six days and if any of you are
interested in in some content while I'm
in Dubrovnik you know some scenery may
be it may be you know me drinking some
beer and chilling you are more than
welcome to follow my Twitter and
Instagram account as well so that's it
basically thank you for watching and I
will see you soon every day but but
really next Wednesday see you soon